Davide Gentile.
- C'est une urgence qui
sert les zones chaudes
du centre-ville de Montréal.
de la crise qui l'a frappéel'an.
- De plus en plus d'infirmières
sont obl
supplémentaire obligatoire.
Il faut que ça change.
- Les infirmières avaient
dénoncé publiquement la charge
Depuis, la direction a réagi.
♪ ♪ ♪
Une vingtaine d'infirmières
- Juste reprendre sa saturo.
st sous oxygène? OK.
- L'infirmière auxiliaire
Dalila Ghelig appules infirmière
Fatoumata Diallo.
- La douleur, elle est
à combien sur 10?
de base comme les prisesde sang,
ce qui laisse plus de temps
aux infi
le travail plus complexe.
FATOUMATA DIALLOère à
l'urgence, Hôpital Notre-Dame
- Ça nous donne plus de temps
pour faire notre évaluation
et pour ne pas "rusher".
- Et l'arrivée des renforts
supplémentaire obligatoire.
- Il y an an,
j'étais obligé de retenir
cinq personnes pour le quart,
alors qu'aujourd'hui, bien,
écoutez, on appelle ça des TSO,
j'en n'ai presque plus, là.
1900 bourses d'études pour
lus d'infirmières
auxiliaires dans toutes
les régions du Qué- On va - On .
- À l'Hôpital Jean-Talon
on soigne aussi le personnel
infirmier. Mais ici,
d'ajointes administratives,comm.
- Claudia, est-ce que tu peux
en stat?
- Claudia est arrifort
avec trois autres agentes
administratives la semaine
Elle fait du travail clérical
et de l'accompagnement,
ce qui donne plus de temps
VALÉRIE ARÈS, infirmière à
l'urgence, Hôpital Jean-Tal
- Je peux être là plus
pour le patient. Déjà là,
qu'on ne pouvait plus
se permettre de fant
des tâches administratives.
- Québec pense aussi que former
fonctionne.
CHRISTIAanté
et Services sociaux, Qc
- On veut aller chercher
- 3000 bourses d'études ont été
offertesis plus tard,
1900 personnes en ont profité.
Un soutien financier essentiel
arrivée de Guinée l'an dernier.
ANANI, agente admin.,
Hôpital Jean-Talon
- Ça bouge beaucoup.ns.
Il faut vraiment être actif.- Ce
dans son pays d'origine,
mais elle est quand mêmeer iciei
un travail moins prestigieux.- e
de la santé a pour objectif
premier d'aider, d. Donc, je. De
partie de cette équipe-là.
Je voudrais, une fois à
la maison, savoir que j'ai pu
- Québec souhaite susciter
plusieurs centaines
d'autres vocations semblables
au cours des prochains mois,
un outil de plus pour tenter de.
Ici Davide Gentil
Radio-Canada, Montréal.